the US State Department says it will
redirect Americans stabilization funding
plan for Syria to other foreign policy
efforts Washington says though this will
not affect its humanitarian assistance
program meanwhile the Saudi Arabia has
pledged to contribute a 100 million
dollars to Syrian reconstruction efforts
however the money will only go up there
northeast of Syria a region under the
control of us back to Kurdish forces and
while some programs are cut others still
remain in place with the u.s. saying it
will stay in Syria for some time yet to
battle terrorists we are remaining in
Syria the focus is the enduring defeat
of Isis we still have not launched the
final phase to defeat the physical
Caliphate this is actually being
prepared now and that will come at a
time of our choosing but it is coming
joshua landis a head of Middle East
Studies at the University of Oklahoma
says there are well multiple competing
interests in Syria
the United States does not want Assad to
become too strong they are hoping to
keep leverage in order to try to push
Iran out of the country to get a better
deal for the Kurds and and of course
they're also worried about what's gonna
happen and it lived province where
there's very complex negotiations and
Russia is at the heart of them so there
are many competing agendas in Washington
and as long as President Trump is not
spending a lot of money there I think
he's happy to keep a few thousand troops
if that increases America's leverage the
United States does not want to spend a
lot of money and that's that's quite
clear and many people have been
complaining bitterly about this
particularly in Raqqa and other areas
that have been quite badly destroyed
they've been pressuring a Saudi Arabia
which just said it would spend another
100 million in Syria stabilization
they've been pushing France and and
European countries to try to get them to
spend more money rather than Washington
this has been one of president Trump's
constant refrains is that others have to
pay for this process
you